[Music]
foreign
watching The Press preview a first look
at what is on the front pages time then
to see what is making the headlines with
the political editors of the guardian
and the song papakura and Harry Cole
with us from now until just before
midnight welcome to both of you lots to
discuss of course so let's take a look
at the front pages the I claims turmoil
within the SNP has delayed the party's
dream of an independent Scotland as
Hamza youssef's voted was was voted to
be the party's new leader
the express has a different take leading
on comments from Rishi sunak who has
vowed to fight for the Union as Mr
Youssef becomes the new leader of the
SNP
front page of the financial times is
Benjamin netanyahu's decision to delay
judicial reforms after days of protests
in Israel
the guardian focusing on during
Lawrence's claims that the Publishers of
the Daily Mail and mail on Sunday had
private investigators to hack her phone
the governor of the bank of England
Andrew Bailey has blamed early
retirements for increased interest rates
and inflation that is the front of the
Delhi Telegraph the Metro says the Home
Secretary is fighting Rebels on both
sides of her party over her plans on
small boats arriving on the south coast
of England
Daily Mail reports on the prime minister
vying to crack down on what they call
nuisance staycation party houses
Only Fools and Horses star so David
Jason reveals in the Delhi mirror
he's met a daughter he did not know he
had for 52 years
and we end with the Daily Star which
says experiments will be carried out in
space to try to tackle Earth's gnostiest
diseases
well a reminder by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
let's head straight to Peppa and to
Harry and straight to Pippa the SNP and
what it means everybody wants to know
four both Independence and four UK
politics
well I mean this is a result that we've
all been uh looking uh forward to
finding out it wasn't clear despite the
fact there was there was three
candidates throughout the race which of
the last two ultimately whether it be
Hamza Yusuf the favorite or whether it
be Keith Forbes who is the uh the budget
the finance secretary um who was a
social conservative and caused ripples
early on and of course we found out that
the continuity candidate homester Yusuf
who was uh Nicholas sturgeon's Heir
Apparent uh won by not a massive margin
didn't win on first preferences but
nevertheless he is going to be confirmed
on Wednesday as Scotland's first
Minister
um and his first the First Act of whomsu
yusuf's leadership of the SNP was to
fire off a letter to Rishi sinach the
Prime Minister demanding a section 30
order which if granted would trigger the
mechanism to allow second Scottish
independence referendum to go ahead now
you might be a bit surprised by that
because of course
the general feeling was that Nicholas
sturgeon had run out of Road in her
attempts to get an independence another
Independence referendum she of course
went to the Supreme Court then she had
that rare internally about whether they
would use the next general election as a
de facto referendum decided against the
plan eventually after some internal
dissent within the SNP so you might
wonder why he's doing why he's doing
that now and it's clear that Nicholas
sturgeon has had that request she did it
um three times 2014 they got a
referendum 2017 and 2019 they didn't and
Danny Street me quite clear that this
time would be no different that a second
referendum would not be granted but uh
Usos allies said that he felt he had to
do that just to show that he was willing
to he was prepared to because of course
ultimately his aim is still in
independent Scotland even if that seems
further away now than it did when
Nicholas sturgeon was still in power yes
the telegraph's take is that he will
also resurrect Nicholas sturgeon's trans
reforms uh the self-identification laws
which got him I got her into
difficulties but even on the front page
of the eye professor John Curtis well
respected says even yes voters May
desert the SNP will he have to fight the
next general election
um Harry on you know things like
education and health because he knows
that's what labor will do and the whole
point is that secure Stormer can turn
around and said yes you can get you know
you can get independence maybe
eventually maybe but right now if you
vote labor you can kick out the Tories
which we know lots of s p voters would
want to do so this is fascinating isn't
it about what this means for the labor
party
yeah I think uh I mean Yusuf is on quite
Shaky Ground if you if he's gonna solely
fight on on domestic issues as Kate
Forbes his opponent said he was a
useless transport secretary he was a
useless Justice secretary he's been a
useless Health secretary what makes you
think he's going to be any better as
first Minister now you can expect to see
that quote on every single labor leaflet
and everything will Tory leaflet
um in in the Scottish elections in the
general elections in local council
elections um the s p have absolutely
ripped each other to shreds in the last
five weeks they're a party that have
been very very good at discipline until
all until the worlds came off when
sturgeon pulled the stumps um just just
five weeks ago so big uphill Mountain
for for him to use of to climb uh and
taking over a very very narrow Victory
probably the victory that will keep the
party together if Kate Forbes would
squeaked it with the SIM in a similar
margin I think the party would be in a
fresh round of Civil War but I think
they will be able to sort of try and put
it together but all he's really left
with is sending far you know letters to
Rishi sunak saying I demand a referendum
well that's not going to happen that was
ruled out within minutes and tonight
you've got both the Tories I think and
labor kind of a hoop that they got
the candidate they wanted they were
quite scared of Nicholas sturgeon in a
way she was seen as a sort of biomass of
Scottish politics they couldn't really
land a governor whereas Yusuf he's got
his terrible track record as a minister
as well as being quite um a prickly
character to deal with
um along the way um his approval rating
actually was higher going into this
campaign than it was when he finished
with it so he's starting from a low bar
tour is tonight privately calling hands
are useless and and various names saying
he's gonna be an asset to the union and
they've got labor going around saying
they think that privately they can win
20 seats on the back of his victory so
it's quite the um quite the low bar that
he's coming into
yes and Labor's battle for SNP votes
um may make them go mute on the fight
for the union which if we look at the
Daily Express paper wish you soon like
is uh all too willing to take up
yes
um that's right I was very struck by the
News Press Conference a separate press
conference I'm sure we'll come until
later the anesthesial behavior stuff
um this morning he was asked about the
union and uh and uh his response his
response was um well when I was in Wales
last week which was a bit confusing but
his point was that he he is a big
supporter of the Union across the board
and of course it is known as the
conservative what is the conservative
and unionist party and it's something
which uh uh as is dear to his heart also
so he tells us
um and
um you know I think his job is probably
keeping the union together it's got a
bit easier of course Boris Johnson was
famously unpopular in Scotland and was
great as gifts that to the SNP when it
came to Tori Tori leaders it's slightly
different with Rishi sunak and as Harry
says Tories will potentially put on some
more votes by not having Kate Forbes who
was socially conservative and risked
probably taking some of their some of
their core vote and also as he says you
know labor labor potentially
um starting to take um 20 you know could
take up to 20 seats or at least 20 seats
are in play which could be the
difference between a next election
between squeaking home or having a sort
of a decent a decent majority they they
don't need to fight I think on the union
they won't that's not where they're
they're planning to fight I think
they're focus more on giving
um on an alternative to to the Tories in
power and focusing on domestic issues
and and what labor could offer
um Scotland
um on the domestic front the summer
won't be able to avoid the the issue of
the Union forever and you know he has he
has been quite clear
um uh after initially sort of a bit of
prevarication and not necessarily this
is some time ago when he first took over
um he's now is as consistently said for
some time that that of course he he
would rule out any deal with the SNP
before or after an election and that um
and that his uh you know his aim is
keeping the union together and it's
interesting that one of the sort of main
attack lines from the Tories in recent
years on the sturgeon at elections has
been a little picture if you remember
that election advert of
um of Ed miliband and Nicola in fact it
was in Alex Salmon's pocket at one point
I think Libra leaders in in Alexander's
pocket and then obviously it became in
Nicholas sturgeon's pocket now voters in
England don't necessarily know who whosf
is so I think the potency of that attack
will have gone with his arrival
um but uh yeah obviously the union still
for Scots is is a key issue but
increasingly I think people in Scotland
are feeling they want to focus on things
like the health system on the schools on
transport rather than necessarily the
Constitutional issues which have
dominated
um in the years of Nicholas sturgeon's
rule yes and in your article um in the
sun Harry you point out that uh his
victory Hamza youssef's victory means
that three of the biggest jobs in
politics that of prime minister that of
Mayor of London and the first minister
of Scotland will all be held by British
Asians in a historic first all sorts of
Records broken today did I also read
that t will be the first Muslim leader
in Western Europe I mean it's amazing
stuff really
yeah and all the the age of 37 which is
incredibly impressive as well so I think
everyone is quite afraid today you saw
this great moment where uh lots of
people like kirstama rushed to rush to
Twitter to say wow what a moment
congratulations and then gave it about
eight seconds before that going but we
just screwed you completely and we're
gonna fight you to the very very end so
no an important moment to Mark whatever
your political persuasion
um an incredible achievement for for
this country uh that lots of people like
to talk down as a horrible isolated
racist Island and you know what an awful
place we are and how how isolated and
terrible we are but actually look at
look at look at look at our achievements
as a country
um we should all be very proud of that
regardless of our political Persuasions
yes the the children of immigrants or
grandchildren of immigrants
um just at a time when immigration is
being so hotly debated in this country
it's a it is interesting certainly uh
let's move to the guardian now your
paper um pepper and Prince Harry in town
photograph of him there um for a case
against the publisher of the Daily Mail
in the mail on Sunday
yes there's a bit of a ripple of
surprise this morning that Prince Harry
turned up at the case we all knew the
case was happening today and Elton John
Elton John um and Dorian Lawrence also
turned up maybe
um slightly uh more expected because of
course they're basically based in the UK
they're based in the UK
um but this is a this is a phone hacking
uh case against
um allegations against the Daily Mail
it's really interesting is that the
males largely escaped these allegations
up until this point
um it obviously previously led to the
closure of the news of the world
um but this is the first major challenge
that could result in in really quite
profound reputational damage and it
relates to the time when Paul daker was
in was in charge or in charge of the
daily mail
um and um the the the most striking I
think the most striking allegation to
come out or testimony to come out is
from Doreen Lawrence who if you remember
back in the 90s when her son uh her son
Stephen was killed killed and the meal
had sort of these campaigning front
pages where it put on pictures of his
his killers and with the word murderers
and basically basically said to them sue
us if you dare
um and uh you know Racine has been
really sort of bold and campaigning I
think I think the background to it was
that um Neville Lawrence Steven's father
knew uh or was Paul dig it was dicker's
um decorator so I had a personal
relationship with him
um but Doreen Lawrence claimed that the
male hired Private Investigations as we
report on the front of the Guardian to
hack her phone and obtain information
about her son potentially disrupting the
police investigation into his racially
motivated killing and she now says in
really moving testimony that she thinks
she failed him by trusting the male at
that time and suggested that the the
paper only campaigned for justice on his
behalf not because of the sort of the
the merits of the case but basically the
cynical bid to sell more newspapers so
it was very it was a pretty sort of
extraordinary hearing and that's before
we got on to sort of some of the
testimony from other some of the other
big names as actors like Liz Hurley and
Sadie Frost amongst them liberal
Democrat politician Simon Hughes um I
mean phone hacking is something which
has plagued the newspaper industry as I
say for for you know a long time now for
a couple of decades and this is this
sort of the latest latest chapter in
this history so we'll all be you know
journalists and Beyond will be watching
closely to see how it all unfolds yeah
indeed so and it means you know the
appearance today uh means that the
coronation of his father is sandwiched
between Court appearances by Prince
Harry uh because the case against mirror
group newspapers uh is due to go to
trial on the 9th of May so you know
straight after the coronation anyway
lots more still to come uh inside the
Sun
oh he's sort of on still anyway inside
the Han headlines jobs homax the prime
minister's three strikes and you're out
rule for tenants talking about that and
plenty more when we come back
[Music]
thank you
well welcome back you are watching The
Press preview with me once again
pipakura and Harry Cole from the
guardian and the sun welcome back to
both of you
um Harry let's go to yeah it's your
paper the sun sorry uh yob's home ax
where she's three strikes and you're at
rule for problem tenants uh the daily
males talking about a Crackdown on
nuisance Airbnb party houses I'm
intrigued by why rashishu next decided
to to tackle anti-social Behavior now
um mainly because it's gonna be an
election in about 14 months time I
suspect and people are really angry
about this stuff um It's all bubbled
under the system and under the radar for
a for a while we we got a lot of noise
um at the weekend and into the papers um
into Monday's papers about banning
hippie crack and laughing gas and and
stopping people you know desecrating
Town centers by by boozing and and
breaking up um breaking up yobo's
um scrubbing graffiti and all the things
we've heard before actually if you drill
down into the detail which is actually
published today there's some quite
sweeping changes that the the the
conservatives are proposing Michael Gove
as ever has done quite a good piece of
work
um on the on the sort of white paper of
the proposals and there's a quite
radical changes to tenancy laws uh
proposed including the ability to for
private landlords to kick people out
um in a matter of weeks if they are
causing disruption and social behavior
partying breaking tenancy agreements
that's going to make that's a big move
to allow landlords to kick people out
also on the social housing side of
things three strikes and you're out this
is a real problem that's been blighting
uh lots of communities and the fact that
that complaints are put into council's
problem tenants are are told off time
and again but it's actually very hard to
evict people the government really want
to strengthen those the laws around that
it will require a change the law to make
it easier to evict people and the other
one that is is as the male person there
Airbnb a sort of almost wild west of of
the reg uh deregulation so far actually
part of the the business model of Airbnb
is complete lack of Regulation around it
but some people commit people we've
spoken to in the paper tomorrow saying
their lives have been ruined by the fact
that they don't know who these landlords
are they buy these Flats they buy these
houses they buy even these Cottages in
small villages and they rent them out to
God knows who and they have wild hot tub
parties until 4am and tenants are going
around the bend because they they
complain but there's by the time
anything's done about it the next
tenants have moved on so in the detail
of this of this come down some really
interesting things okay I'm moving on
only because the Metro is going with
Jeremy corbyn the prospect of him being
booted out of Labor the prospect two of
him standing as an independent our
correspondent Liz Bates caught up with
him today
can we just very quickly ask you if
you're thinking of standing as an
independent Mr Corbin very much I'm
going to the demonstration against the
immigration bill and I suggest you
report that too we are reporting it it
will take 10 seconds
I just want to talk to you for 10
seconds about your futures thank you
very much
yeah not too happy about that is this
for political reasons Pippa
well he's expecting him to see actually
that he was going to stand as an
independent but he's clearly not made
his mind up yet now this is something
which the Libra is ruling NEC committee
is going to talk about tomorrow
um they're going to confirm uh that
Corbin won't be allowed to stand as a
labor candidate
um obviously this is something that
Kirsten talked about a month ago when
the um the equality Human Rights
Commission uh ruled on it it sort of
gave its final final verdict on on labor
clearing up anti-Semitism
um but interestingly the motion on which
the committee are going to be the nec's
going to be voting tomorrow doesn't
mention anti-Semitism it basically says
that were Corbin to run as a labor
candidate it would damage Libra's
chances at the next election amongst key
voters it needs uh to win so they've
obviously just concluded that actually
um amongst those possibly red Walland
and other parts of the country uh Corbin
isn't very popular better off without
him clearly very controversial among
some of the members because they think
it should be up to the members of his
local constituency to decide so you know
I think the runner will rumble on for a
bit within inside the labor party but I
think um you know Stormer is not going
to meet much objection outside the labor
party and certainly amongst those voters
who were put off by Corbin at the last
election